inside Demi Lovato's recovery and what
led to her downward spiral Beyonce
gifted us a rare picture of her twins
Rumi and sir and the internet thinks
chrissy teigen played with a deadly bug
hey guys this is the daily Denny the
stories run the gamut today my friends
they really do Beyonce and jay-z are
back in the states after the epic
European leg of their on the run to tour
but clearly the Carters enjoy the fruits
of their labor based on these regal
vacay pics be shared on her website it's
where we got a rare glimpse of twins
Rumi and sir
that's Rumi on the right with a big old
toothy smile sir is a little more
serious on the left but who do you guys
think they look more like Beyonce jay-z
or both now it's the first official
close-up of the 13 month old twins since
their birth announcement last July
Beyonce and jay-z
rarely post about the twins we're told
they want to protect the image of their
children and allow fans to see their
children when they want them to a source
also tells et quote the twins are happy
babies and blue is a great sister the
family has enjoyed being on tour
together and sharing time together all
over the world yeah I'd say so
check out my spirit animal and life
goals Blue Ivy Carter the carter
children are clearly living their best
lives look at that diva and I'm like
dear Beyonce and jay-z adopt me well
last night Beyonce and jay-z kicked off
the North American leg of their tour in
Cleveland B showed off her figure in
these bedazzled denim hot pants and
servant Boggy I mean look at her tiny
waist y'all I gotta say it's this red
bedazzled number that's got me
completely
see the crowd going [ __ ] I cannot wait
to see on the run - with my own eyes
when they are in LA in September but
meanwhile Amber Rose is stirring the pot
y'all she appeared on Spencer and Heidi
Pratt podcast make Spidey famous again
and we don't even have time to get into
that tragic podcast named because amber
revealed her conclusion to the long
debated question who is Becky with the
good hair I do know Gwyneth Paltrow has
gone like Becky with the good hair I
really feel like she's what does that
mean jay-z oh oh because they were even
they were friends and then like they you
don't see Gwyneth Paltrow with Beyonce
anymore and it just seems like she was
the one I was Canadian now when it lost
her husband but like Beyonce still Agyei
I don't even know what to say to that
Beyonce and GUP have been close friends
and true we haven't really seen them
interact with each other or their
families in a minute but like they
hardly ever post about each other right
well here's the last time we spoke to
Gwyneth about Beyonce it was right after
we announced her pregnancy in February
last year how excited are you for her
that she's gonna be the mom of twins
very excited babies are always a good
thing babies bring good luck okay
actually not sure that helps my defense
of win it butter up for the actress
tells et the whole story is completely
absurd and a hundred percent false in
the meantime the Carter family may be
back to work but the legends are
enjoying a little family vacation of
their own in Bali but it almost turned
lethal when chrissy teigen start playing
with a poisonous bug with luna
a bag it's a bug is he a nice bug or do
you don't give him a kiss well it didn't
take long for the internet to chime in
followers claim it's a tarantula hawk
wasp that apparently lays eggs inside
tarantula spiders and those eggs slowly
eat them inside and I am screaming Luna
was trying to kiss it now it is
unconfirmed what kind of creature it
actually was but to put the trolls at
ease Chrissy followed up with this the
only one getting kick out of this she
also tweeted that she the bug our
friends now and perhaps with time lovers
right but we do need to switch gears
right now I know it's a bit of a hard
pivot but I want to give you guys the
latest news inside Demi Lovato's
recovery and what we're learning about
the seniors downward spiral before her
drug overdose et has learned Demi
Lovato's team staged an intervention for
the singer about a month ago urging her
to go to rehab she rejected the plan and
overdosed Tuesday morning at her home in
the Hollywood Hills now multiple sources
tell et that just hours before Demi OD
she attended a birthday party at saddle
ranch Chop House in West Hollywood
we're told the partying extended into
the early hours of Tuesday morning at
Denny's house meanwhile Jamie's ex
Wilmer Valderrama went to visit the
Seeger yesterday at cedars-sinai Medical
Center source tells a teen Wilmer was
shattered by the overdose news and
didn't anticipate this are we have
plenty more on Demi up at et online.com
tomorrow I'll be back with the latest
and of course new music Friday